this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists hello everybody welcome to
the minimalist podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists happy
new year ryan
thank you what a great excuse to start
over
let's talk about kicking off the new
year with some friendly decluttering now
for many of you listen to this this may
be
your first time listening to the
minimalist podcast because
our new documentary directed by matthew
vela called less is now which is amazing
it just came out on netflix
and you all saw that and you said i need
more of these two goofy guys from dayton
ohio
and so here you are asking about
decluttering asking about starting your
year off
right many of you have stuck around
there are millions of you have stuck
around
over the uh the past few years we've
been doing this podcast thank you for
sticking around welcome to anyone
who is new who just came from netflix
that new documentary if you haven't
checked it out already it's called
less is now you can find it in 190
countries they say ryan you're so
popular yeah it's in 30 different
languages
you're overdubbed in german i can't wait
to hear that
i just didn't realize i'd have to learn
30 new languages
to produce this documentary you didn't
you were just a lot of work
you were just making sounds on the
overdubs and told them you knew the
language
yeah anyway let's talk about the problem
with uh new year's
resolutions i know it's that time you've
already made one and
it's the this comes out on the fifth day
of the year so many of them have already
been broken
yeah people want to run a marathon a day
or
lose 10 pounds a day
yeah and so i think that's actually the
problem with new year's resolutions is
they're too big and i used to always
think they were sort of
crap for a while like why would i want
to do a new year's resolution but i do
see a point to it
when it is inspiring if you're actually
going to have a goal i'm sort of a no
goals
guy myself but if you're going to have a
goal you want something that aspire
inspires you to
take action yeah and because if it
doesn't do that if it's
overwhelming if it's distressing if it
makes you restless
it's probably not a good objective in
the first place yeah
i mean just doing a new year's
resolution because your friends are
doing it
yeah it's also a really bad reason
unless it's the 30-day minimalism game
and the one thing that uh right exactly
josh tell us about the 30-day minimalism
game the minimalist.com
game uh no i was going to say
resolutions
you know you can have a resolution any
day it doesn't just have to be new years
now i know it is new year's
yeah so um that's when it seems like
people are motivated to make a new
year's resolution but guess what if it's
you know january 5th right now and
you didn't make a new year's resolution
you could still do that on january 5th
yeah and it's still a new year
yeah relative to a week ago right or two
weeks ago or three
yeah so yes it's never too late to start
i always encourage people to start out
with something
small and today we're going to talk
about getting started with decluttering
a lot of people
are are going to be new here today but
also it's a time of year where we just
kind of need this refresher even
even us as the titular minimalists yeah
we
need a refresher we often have to
declutter our own homes
yeah and many of our questions are
associated with that today but before we
get
into our audience questions or phone
calls here
i just want to talk about decluttering
we also think about decluttering our
homes
but i think there's sort of this i don't
know the the decluttering
trinity of locations what i mean by that
is
our homes for sure but if you want to
get some quick momentum
if you have an office separate from
where you live i know a lot of us are
working from home these days yeah
but decluttering your office is usually
way easier than decluttering
your home and you spend so much time
there anyway
yeah that can be a great place to get
started we'll talk about some tactics uh
throughout this episode to do that but
then also your
car you're probably driving in it to
work every day
it's funny um when we were filming less
is now
the last day of filming matt had me come
over to his house
and he's he he bought he brought a bunch
of junk i don't know where he got a
bunch of junk from
probably his wife how dare you
i think she he always says she's not a
minimalist i think she's more of a
minimalist than him
oh yeah it's always the great excuse for
us minimalist we can just say we pawn
our stuff off on other people
right exactly they're not minimalist hey
honey i know i can't hold on to this
anymore you hold on to it it's like that
episode of the simpsons where
homer bought marge a bowling ball that
said homer on it for
christmas yeah yeah yeah it's kind of
what us minimalists really do
that simpsons was good anyway well um
the day i went over to matt's he filled
my glove box
over uh he overflowed it with stuff so
much stuff
so that there's a quick scene in the in
the documentary
where i open up the glove box but he you
couldn't see his hand he had to change
the shot
he had to hold the glove box shut with
one hand while he filmed with the other
hand because
it was so full of stuff and he figured i
was already gonna have stuff in there so
he could he
he comes out to my car and he's like all
right let's put some stuff in there he
opens it
it's completely pitch black glove box
with one
black envelope in it yeah because of ocd
uh and you know it just has my
registration and everything in there
but i keep absolutely nothing what about
your owner's manual
yeah it's on google yeah i know isn't
that funny man like manuals and
instructions and
yeah it's like we hold on to those
things every time i get anything like
that yeah i think the same thing i'm
like i can totally just find this on
google yeah i have a 2015
toyota and so if
i really if i imagine it broke down the
side of rome i'm going to get out the
manual and just be like hmm
all right let me flip here to page 63.
have the hood up i'm just going to fix
it on the side of the road no of course
i'm not going to do that
right so my car has next to nothing
in it in fact one of our youtube videos
youtube.com
the minimalists we did a a little one of
our living room conversations we took a
field trip to my car and i just showed
people
what was in my car i think i even have
less now than
what i did in that video you can check
that out we'll put it on the list
yeah we'll put a link to it in the show
notes but car office
and then home we're gonna be talking a
lot about decluttering all three of
those spaces i want you to remember
though that organizing isn't really
decluttering
and this is a distinction that we often
get confused we use these words
synonymously right yeah i'm just gonna
get organized
well that's often the problem yeah yeah
we will go to the container store
we'll buy a bunch of cheap plastic
things to hide
not hold our stuff but hide our stuff to
get it out of the way
and it gives us this false sense of
security
i'll just have that just in case or hold
on to that just in case and we'll be
talking a lot today about just in case
items yeah our first question today is
from jennifer in st
joseph michigan i'm calling in to ask
about
a packing party i'm considering having
one i
start having it and then i end up going
through things
and it takes a lot longer i think than
just packing things up in a box
is the point to not look at the stuff
and just pack it up and pull it out when
you need it i just feel myself getting
hung up
and looking at everything also is it
possible or do you have any tips
for how to have a packing party for my
kids things
maybe getting them involved or do i just
do it and
pull things out as they ask for it so
ryan let's talk to
new listeners briefly about what the
packing party is although of course they
saw
the elements a recreation of the packing
party in less is now
the new film but uh for those who are
uninformed or just need a refresher what
did you do for your packing party
so when i first started my minimalist
journey i didn't know where to start
and uh you and i came up with this great
idea for a packing party where we
decided to pack up all my belongings as
if i were moving
and then i would unpack only the items i
needed over the next
three weeks so we packed up literally
every single thing in my house
even your furniture be covered with
sheets and stuff exactly exactly
so as i needed things i went to boxes i
uncovered furniture
and it was it was kind of the beginning
of our website theminimalists.com
because
i remember the the the perspective shift
that i got with that and i knew that
there were more people out there who
would get something out of this out of
that story
right so um with uh with jennifer's
question here
the biggest mistake she is making is
going through all her stuff yes
before she's packing up the packing yeah
exactly like pretend you're moving you
put everything
in a box you pack up every if you're
going through your things of course
you're going to want to hold on to 50 of
it just in case or because it's
sentimental
uh the whole idea of a packing party is
you don't know what's in those boxes
all you know is that you're gonna need
things as time goes on you need your
toothbrush
you need your bed and bed sheets you
need some clothes for work
uh you need your hair dryer josh i'm
just you don't even have a hair dryer do
you of course
i do oh you do look at this hair if
you're watching on youtube i thought
that was just natural
i thought you woke up like that my hair
dryer is all natural so so yeah uh if
you're but if you're gonna i did not go
through my stuff
um i i remember going through my stuff
when the packing party was over to see
if i wanted to get rid of things
right and uh the sentimental stuff was
by far the hardest stuff to get rid of
because like i'd look in the shoebox i'm
like oh yeah
yeah here's like some stuff from high
school here's you know whatever it is
oh man do i really want to like i can't
really like
donate this no one's gonna want letters
from my mom
um yeah so you know but to recycle them
just to let them go away
uh it was a little tough so
i did get through the sentimental stuff
eventually but um yeah i would recommend
not going through your stuff
as you're packing packing it up the
whole idea is you just
as things come to mind that's when you
want to go grab them yeah i need this
thing so i'm going to go
grab it i think that what's encouraging
about this she's asking like
what i hear in her voice is like is this
even possible like i know this ryan did
this
but could this work for anyone else and
the truth is we've seen well
probably over more than 100 people do
packing parties now sure well over 100
actually i don't know what i'm saying
but we've we actually catalogued 47 of
them so we have a book coming out later
this year called love people
use things we're actually talking about
that the end of the show it's now
available for pre-order love people use
things.net
someone uh parked on the dot com some
jerk
really toward us oh wow yeah love people
use things.net
is where you can find that.net's cool
yeah it's retro
yeah it is anyway in the book we we what
we did is we took 47 different
families individuals and you know people
with kids or just married couples
whatever
and they did one of three versions of
the packing party and so they could do
what ryan did the
extreme version or the most extreme
version which
is a whole house packing party where you
box up everything
pretend you're moving and then unpack
things only as you need them
or you can do one room
if you just want you need a baby step to
sort of get started it's a very big baby
step
you said it earlier start in the office
yeah like just pick one split space
that's really really cluttered that you
know you could benefit from a packing
party right and choose that maybe it's
your desk
right it could be it could be any room
or we also had some people who did
multi-room packing parts so maybe they
wanted to do their kitchen
and their garage and and then unpack
only the things in those rooms as they
need it
what i found is that as you get momentum
it does
get easier and easier by the day you
feel freer and lighter
and if a packing party though is too
extreme
for you then you probably want to
consider the 30-day minimalism game
which we alluded to earlier
but that that allows you to get some
momentum so maybe you do the 30-day
minimalism game
for a month that'll give you enough
momentum to move into
a packing party i mean yeah maybe that's
what i know as i said maybe that's what
i should have done but
i'm just i need something extreme to
happen in my life
unfortunately for me to shift my
perspective so
uh choosing the extreme thing is a lot
better than it just happening to me
sure um but yeah what's interesting too
jennifer talked about her kids
right how do i do a kid it might seem a
little extreme with kids but you know
kids love to help um so just you know
talk to your kids about like hey look
we're going to pack up everything
we're going to do an experiment and uh
we want you to participate and
don't let your kids go through every
single thing because of course they're
going to want to hold on to everything
right
but uh yeah see what the kids are asking
for
as time goes on i mean of course like
the first night you're gonna have to
uncover their bed
yeah put a pillow down and all that
stuff um but yeah
i think with kids it's it's just as
useful um especially if your kid
how many toys does the average kid have
like average kids millions almost 300
they play with only 12 days
crazy yeah that's great yeah and so i
think what you'll what you'll actually
get out of this for your kids is they'll
get more value from the toys they
actually
play with because they're not watered
down by 300
other toys that are effectively useless
and
they're they're clutter they're
literally getting in
the way jennifer i'm going to recommend
you download for free over the
minimalists.com
game there's a 30 day minimalism game
calendar the way the minimalism game
works is it's
on the first day you get rid of you
partner up with someone friend family
member co-worker whomever
and your mortal enemy
if you'd like and over the course of 30
days or 31 days in a month
you get rid of as many items as well
as you can whoever goes the longest wins
and the way that works is you get rid of
one item
on the first day two hours on the second
day three items on the third day so
forth and so on starts off really easy
gets more difficult by the mid month and
by the end of the month
you you know you've gotten rid of nearly
500 items which is a phenomenal start
and would definitely prepare you for a
packing party but we do have a free
minimalism game calendar that you can
download over at
theminimalists.com game
we have a question here from china in
colorado
i currently have a car that doesn't do
well in the mountains
and i live in the mountains i have a
boyfriend whose family
has given us a car and we also have
another car in addition to that
so we have a total of three cars and
also the most amazing bus system
currently i'm paying to have my car
stored because it's winter
and i can't keep it out in the
conditions
but i'm just wondering if i should sell
it or keep it
i know you've talked about the power of
letting go
and say me and my partner were to break
up
i'd love to have a car so i'm stuck in
this place of wondering
do i keep the car just in case or do i
sell it
because it could be worth something and
it's paid off
so should you sell it i'm not going to
tell you what you should do i'll tell
you what i would do
if i were in your situation china by the
way congratulations for asking this
question i think it's really
important congratulations for all for
also for having a paid off
car that's wonderful that's awesome
however you have three cars it sounds
like
i'm assuming based on your the way your
message read to me
it sounds like you don't have a car
payment on any of those
and if that's the case great if you have
a car payment on any of them
there's no such thing as a good car
payment you don't ever there's
no reason to ever ever ever have a car
payment
debt is terrible i never want you to go
into debt to have a car
so if you have a car that has a car
payment i definitely would encourage you
to either pay it off you can't afford to
pay it off
then sell the car even if you're in the
red
so you can pay that off get a car that
you can afford well what do you know
what does that mean
it means if you can afford it well if
you can pay for it
actually pay for it now put it on a
credit card not finance
for 83 months or 48 months or whatever
if you can actually pay for it that
means
you can afford it now you're in a
situation where you have three cars
and two people it's very difficult for
two people to drive three cars at the
same time yeah
and so yes i would definitely if i were
in your shoes
get rid of one of those cars
because you don't need three cars or at
least
i know me and my wife we don't need
three cars yeah
well it's interesting she said that
she's holding on to one car in case her
and her boyfriend break up
which i mean you could take that so far
why don't you store an extra dining set
and an extra couch
and you know or if someone offers you a
couch yeah you might as well take it and
put in storage in case you and your
boyfriend break up
right sounds like a really bad excuse to
hang on to something to me
um it's like i have a prosthetic arm
just in case my arm falls off
i get yeah man it's it's uh it's
interesting the
the reasons we come up with to hang on
to things
yeah i'll tell you if you are trying to
have a contin
a contingency plan for you and your
boyfriend breaking up
then you should have an emergency fund
so yes
you know mariah and i we've been
together for seven years
um i will probably be with her the rest
of my life
uh she has an emergency fund i have an
emergency we have two separate emergency
funds
um she has enough in that emergency fund
i don't even know what it is it's it's
ten thousand bucks something like that
but it's enough to where uh if she
needed to go out and buy a car she could
get
you know a reasonable uh
reasonably priced car um she could pay a
few months worth of rent
yada yada like that's that's the
contingency plan it's not hanging on to
everything that you can
so uh actually mariah she had a
we had two cars she had a car payment on
on hers
and she sold it she paid off the car
the car loan and she had a couple grand
extra to put into the emergency fund
that's great so um yeah i'm with you i
would all if it was me i would also sell
it
but yeah don't don't don't make excuses
to hold on to things like you're
obviously
itching to get rid of this that's why
you're calling in and asking us about it
so
um yeah do what you need to do we just
want you to be happy with your life and
if
the car makes you extraordinarily happy
sitting in storage and paying those
storage fees then you know what great
keep your car yeah but it doesn't sound
like it's making you very happy no it's
definitely not a blessing on your life
right now it's additional payment
so you're paying money to store it
you're obviously paying for insurance on
it or at least i certainly hope you're
paying for insurance on it right
that's an additional cost it's in
storage so you're paying
two payments there that you aren't for
the thing you're not even using
you're also paying to ride the bus
system which congratulations you live
somewhere with a phenomenal bus system
and you're able to use that and you feel
good about it that's even better so that
is a backup to me that's the emergency
backup for you it's not the
the car is you have a phenomenal bus
system you said right
and so having an emergency system is
great but also
being able to differentiate between
emergency items
and just in case it's emergency items
are the only just in case items
ryan and i agree that we need in our
life
so for example having a first aid kit at
home
i certainly hope that i don't need it
and and i don't use it
it doesn't fit within the 90 90 rule
which is one of the rules in our
minimalist rule book
and and so you know what it's a just in
case item and i'm like well i don't want
any justice case size we have a just in
case rule
that's called called the 2020 rule right
that's also in the minimalist rule book
and and so these rules help us establish
some boundaries here but i also realize
that occasionally there is an emergency
item that i need to hold on to
for me a car just in case my
relationship ends
is not an emergency item yeah and it's
not even a just for win item unless you
were certain that that
the relationship was going to end you
would have it just for when it ends
and so i totally agree with ryan i think
having a good emergency fund set up is
going to be important for you but then
also setting up some rules in your own
life
hey sean let's send chyna a copy of
the minimalist rule book we just put it
out on audiobook
you can also download it for free as a
free ebook at theminimalists.com
resources you can find all of our free
resources over there
but if you want the audiobook version of
it it's uh we'll put a link to that in
the show notes
as well ryan what time is it it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
your text messages text your questions
and comments to
937-202-4654
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones and we
personally reply to as many as we can we
can't respond to everyone but we do
respond to a few of those
we also answered them on the podcast now
during the lightning round this is where
ryan and i do our best to answer every
question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share or pick the
answers on social media
if you'd like and now you can find all
of our minimal maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com nick wants to know
once you declutter how do you keep from
the clutter coming back
so so this is a fascinating question
because i mean the typo not withstanding
but um it's almost like a freudian slip
there right right
but the people often think of
minimalism as a destination
but minimalism is not the destination
minimalism is
the vehicle that's not my pithy answer
but you can tweet that podcast shawn
damn and so i i want you to think about
it this way
what ryan and i use minimalism for is to
live a more deliberate life
that includes with less stuff but there
are times
where ryan and i we still have to bring
new things into
our life we do so deliberately but over
time
sometimes those things stop adding value
and so when they stop adding value
we have to be willing to let go here's a
pithy answer for you the most effective
way to de-clutter
is to leave the junk at the store
and so there's always going to be a
point where you have to continue to
de-clutter it's probably not going to be
the same volume if you're one of those
people
like the average american who has 300
000 items in their house i know because
i was one of them
when you get started you're gonna be
decluttering a lot but even once you've
reached the point of decluttering
or maybe even you could say you're a
minimalist
there's going to be a point where you
start to let go of stuff new things that
come in
so always be willing to let go nick well
our circumstances constantly change
right yes so
you might like mariah and i live in a
studio apartment right now
right uh eventually we'll have kids and
we'll have another bedroom
so we'll need things for that child and
for that
bedroom for like for the kid totally so
um
yeah uh like you said minimalism is not
a destination it is a tool
used to live a deliberate life so
don't um don't beat yourself up if you
get a little bit of clutter in your life
that that's okay
that's that's why you have minimalism in
your life so you can handle it as
you start to notice it i know like i was
watching uh
i don't know a few months back i was
watching hoarders yeah and
it made me question everything i had and
i
but i did i looked at our bookshelf i'm
like i have a bookshelf and it's
full because it's there and my my rule
is
is like oh we don't you know we don't
have more books than can fit on the
bookshelf
but even that i'm like that's still kind
of silly so i got rid of half the books
and now half of it's empty and
yeah it actually aesthetically looks uh
pretty good and you're no longer a
secret order that's right exactly
um here's my pithy answer a life without
boundaries is a house without
walls so
yeah it's uh that doesn't exist it
doesn't exist
you you've got to have some boundaries
set up in life i mean the you know the
boundaries we have in life
um and just like walls in a home it
keeps things
from going out and it keeps things from
coming in it works both ways
so uh you've got to have some boundaries
if not then you're going to have
out of control life you know real quick
before we move on to our listener tips
ryan i just wanted to say that
there was something that that resonated
with me there when you were talking
about you and mariah and if you had kids
obviously you would
need to have another bedroom unless you
know you're just putting a crib in your
studio and that could work for a period
of time
it may not be ideal though and so
minimalism isn't about deprivation it's
about finding the most
ideal situation for you and usually that
means
owning less but in time that might mean
incorporating more into your life as
your
life changes and i think the prime
example here is if you go look at our
two documentaries
you look at our first one minimalism
which came out in 2016.
and we filmed it in 2014 so how old was
i then i was uh 32
at the time oh my god i'll be 40 this
year oh my goodness
right so so uh i'll be 40 this year and
if you look at
the the new documentary less is now
and you look at my home in that one
compared to my home
when i was single without a kid in
when i was 32 they're completely
different right places and and so
it doesn't mean that one is more
minimalist than the other
it's they're both are appropriate for
that stage of my life
and so when you compare the two it's not
equating them necessarily it's just
saying
this was appropriate for me then this is
appropriate for me now
as what is appropriate changes i need to
be willing to change
the things that surround me all right
ryan before we get into our listener
tips on our added value
segment today you're gonna like the
added value a lot
it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
what are joshua and ryan's own new
year's resolutions this year
what's the difference between
decluttering and going minimalist
and how do you deal with the journals
and notebooks
when decluttering how do you organize
paper clutter what documents do we
really
need to save how do i get rid of most of
my cleaning supplies and which cleaning
supplies
should a minimalist own how do i
convince my
spouse to declutter how can i avoid
feeling guilty about getting rid
of stuff plus a million more questions
for the minimalists and
if you want to hear all that subscribe
to our maximal episodes on the
minimalist
private podcast it's a completely
separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because
we don't believe in advertisements by
the way if you're not a private podcast
subscriber you're literally missing
two-thirds or more
of our show you can try it out for a
month try it out for three weeks
see whether or not you really enjoy it
what we're aiming to do is add immense
value to your life with our private
podcast
it allows us to go deep it allows us to
say things that might get us cancelled
in public
but our our supporters are real
subscribers they they let us fail
out loud and uh sort of stumble through
a private podcast but it's much more
intimate that way
and how what do you how do you feel
about those conversations we have on the
private podcast ryan
oh man i actually feel more relaxed when
we're having those conversations i can
let my hair down literally
he looks down to me now but
uh no i i'm so glad we have that
platform to try out new ideas
and to be honest too like it's a it's a
group of people
that i can look at their feedback and
like take it in
and not be uh concerned about um
criticism and critics and their motives
and seagulls yeah it's it's a very
it's a very awesome platform and i am
extremely grateful for it yes indeed so
if you are a supporter of the podcast
thank you so much
we're gonna be talking a lot more this
week on the
maximal episode about decluttering and
new year's resolutions
and a whole lot more try it out the
minimalists.com
support it's just two bucks by the way
so
we're gonna give you way more than your
two dollars worth and of course
you can walk away at any time the
minimalists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app there's also a video version over
there as well if you prefer to watch
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
my name is sabrina carlton i'm from
flagstaff
arizona i've been listening to and
enjoying your podcast and its
inspiration
very much and i so appreciate it i
wanted to leave a tip for listeners
today
about both the mindful acquisition of
new clothing as well as
mindfully getting rid of clothing as
someone who does a lot of outdoor
adventure
myself including in the winter time one
of the pieces of clothing that we often
struggle with is our base layers or our
long jaunt and
they are pretty necessary for
adventuring in cold weather whether
you're skiing snowboarding snowshoeing
or just building snowmen in the front
yard
base layers can often be pretty ill so
ill-fitting poorly made
the fabrics are not always very
environmentally sustainable it's
certainly something that i have
struggled with
plenty of times i recently came to know
about this
clothing company started by a husband
and wife's team it's called carbeau
clothing
and they created their company to fix
this exact problem they
focus exclusively on base layers and
they make all of their things to fit and
perform well
all of it's made out of sustainable
fabrics and it's made in apps in
colorado
it is pricier of course than some of the
cheaper things you're going to find
but it is well worth the price in my
opinion but even better than that
they have a mission and a non-profit arm
they call
join the flight and this company allows
you to donate
new or gently used cold weather outdoor
gear for distribution to porters and
guides in third world countries
westerners including the founders of
this company
in traveling to these several countries
to fly mountains have created
a demand for guide services and that's
great for the local economy for these
people
but often now these people are going to
altitude and temperatures that they
don't have the proper clothing to be at
and that is putting them
in a safety situation so the founders of
corvo clothing
will collect donations of these new or
gently used
items that maybe you know someone gave
it to you it's not a color you like or
just doesn't fit you put to your
to your liking and they'll take them and
they collect them and then once or twice
a year they go to these communities
personally the founders actually go and
hand off these items to the people
in those communities so you know that
they're getting into the hands of the
right people
i think that's just incredibly
incredibly cool how they have seen
problems
in their industry and are working to
solve it so
um if you want to check them out they
are online
if you want to check out their products
or the join the flight campaign
corporateclothing.com corporate
is the french word for raven it's
spelled c-o-r-b-e-a-u-x
um really cool people really interesting
company that i thought the lizards might
like to know about
hey josh and ryan this is morgan from
seattle and soon to be san luis obispo
california
i watched your documentary in april 2017
and it inspired me immediately
over the following five days i spent 25
hours going through all my things
i went to your lessons now stop in
seattle and now after 10 months
i've taken a dozen car fulls of items to
goodwill saved a lot of money and freed
up a significant amount of time
we're going to do the pacific crest
trail this year and getting rid of
things has helped to significantly
reduce the stress around moving
i've developed a couple helpful
approaches that i think may also help
others so i thought i might share one i
got rid of all my duplicates unless they
were consumables
i donated unused shower gels and lotions
to craft supplies and journals to the
elementary school near my home
and stopped buying trinkets when i
visited new places
ultimately i now only allow for one
duplicate if it's a consumable and no
duplicates if i know it'll take me
months to use up
like a journal two for sentimental items
the single most helpful thing i've done
is channel your phrase our memories are
inside of us
not our things and on top of that
i love allow myself time my grandpa
passed away last year which allowed me
to help my mom go through my
grandparents 50 years worth of things
and exercise my newfound minimizing
skills
there were a lot of memories from my mom
who i must say did an impressively well
job with the whole process
but i felt good about being able to see
the things those things and not
artifacts of my grandparents i did keep
four things from my
from their house a lamp a silver
four-leaf clover
an old compact desk and a necklace from
my grandma
now as time passes it's easier to
imagine parting with some of these
things
as well and they may make it into my
next men's game
lastly i have made these changes one
step at a time
over the last couple months i found
myself naturally focusing on one aspect
of my life
at first it was decluttering then it was
finding
my quote-unquote y for not consuming
items
then it was working on having good
conversations with friends and family
around
the change i was making through it all i
have found it helpful to write a few
relevant minimal maxims on index cards
and post them
on my desk at work sometimes i'll also
take a picture of those and make them my
phone
background this gives me a daily
reminder of what i'm focusing on and
helps me internalize the approach that i
know i want but sometimes have a hard
time staying consistent with in practice
all right for our added value segment
this week
ryan my friend canyon city yeah
he has a new ep out and sweet it's
called circling the sun it just came out
at the end of this podcast we're gonna
get we got permission to play his song
like the stars shine such a beautiful
project i mean you know everything he
does is gorgeous but
there's something about this one that i
don't know it his music always feels
like home to me
no matter where i am we could be in the
middle of the desert filming
something we could be here in l.a we'll
be back home in in dayton ohio we can be
in
montana and when i put his music on
it feels like home yeah so brilliant so
at the end of this episode check out
like the stars shine on kenyan city's
new ep it's called
circling the sun we'll put a link to
that in the show notes
ryan real quick what's up right here
right now
there is one thing that's going on in
life of the minimalist and this is big
big news love people use things
our new book which comes out in july
is available for pre-order nice so
you can check it out love people use
things dot
and if you pre-order it's not just like
well i don't want to wait months and
months to get this book okay
you might have to wait some months but
you're going to get a bunch of things
in the meantime up front things that
you're actually not going to be able to
get if you don't pre-order
the book because if you pre-order the
book it really helps us it helps our
publisher et cetera et cetera are we
just going to send them random things
yes just uh like i have a donation box
and i'll just like pick random things or
search
anything about it oh a medium cardigan
nice
sweet yeah no uh we're not gonna send
you things like that oh there are a
couple physical things
that i really like that when we we we
were very deliberate about the things we
chose
uh with respect to this new book love
people use things we'll talk about the
book here briefly but uh there's a
smartphone wallpaper that you'll get a
lot of people use things smartphone
wallpaper but also
bumper stickers more than one uh oh wow
so so you'll have a lot of people use
things
as just your bumper sticker if that's
what you want or you can place that
sticker anywhere else you want on the
bottom of ryan's skateboard perhaps yeah
um a ton of stickers on there computer
stickers so you can cover up whatever
logos on the back of your
dell or whatever you're you're holding
on to these days
so computer stickers oh and uh bookmarks
do i have they're in the other room but
you've already seen that it's a
beautiful bookmark yeah yeah so it's
really cool you get some bookmarks
as well let's talk about why we wrote
the book ryan we we wrote the book
because
well we don't we don't really have a
relationship book out there yeah
well you know what i like about the book
and maybe
you'll have a difference of opinion here
but people often ask
hey you know ryan i get the whole
minimalism thing
i get living deliberately but the
problem is
is like i still want to own a bunch of
stuff i still want to make a ton of
money
and you know intellectually i can get
there that that's not happiness but
emotionally
i can't get there i still really have
that feeling how do i make that feeling
go away i have been asked that a million
times and i don't have a great answer
for that i mean
i don't have a great elevator pitch
answer right for that
but this book i think addresses that
question in the sense that it shows you
what relationships to focus on so that
way you do feel like you're living a
meaningful life and what i have realized
through minimalism
is that when i focus on uh having a good
relationship with my stuff a good
relationship with people a good
relationship with my finances
once i have those relationships in a
place that
um that i feel good then a lot of my
desires go away i mean i still
see the shiny new iphone and i'm like
ooh that looks nice or a new computer or
something but
um it doesn't pull at me like it used to
pull at me because i am genuinely happy
with
what i have now you could you know put
me in a tent in the middle of the desert
i probably sweat to death but if but
other than sweating to death
um you know if as long as i had my wife
with me and and able to
have contact with friends like i i
really feel like i could still live a
very meaningful life
yeah yeah i think with with this book in
particular i love what you said there
because
we have we have three books out there
already there's sort of this
there's a memoir a self-help book and an
essay collection
this one is a relationship book but as
you just alluded to
it's not just about relations with
people so it's not your traditional
relationship book
that's in there i mean it's in the title
either love people
use things and in the book we even talk
about where that title comes from
and sort of dual origin of of that title
but with love people use things it's
figuring out what's in the way and for
most of us
in today's society that's our stuff and
it's our distractions
and it's dealing with those but then
forming a good relationship with our
stuff it's not
doing without stuff it's having a good
relationship with our stuff and then
having a good relationship with the
truth a good relationship with ourselves
that's often a struggle for many of us
self-love right
and so that relationship we call them
the seven essential relationships
there's values and there's money there's
creativity and then
there's our relationship with people
it's actually my favorite chapter in the
book is the
relationship with people chapter but we
walk you through
these seven essential relationships it
starts with the stuff because our
material possessions are a physical
manifestation
of our internal lives so we tackle the
out
the outside clutter the external clutter
and then we look inward and start
dealing with
that internal clutter and that's really
what the book helps us do so we can
improve
our relationship in all of those areas
it's called love people use things love
people use things.net we'll put a link
to that in
the show notes as well you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tour to find a city
near you if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast the minimalist
dot com you can comment on this episode
at youtube.com
the minimalists and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
you also receive our simple sunday
emails each week
and if you leave here today with just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
i reach to pull you down letting go is
harder than it sounds
did you know that most days i'm just
lost
does it show little ways we talk
but i feel lonely
[Music]
when all i had to do was love
you stronger than the battle
of the shadows
louder than the rattles of the night
farther than the water falling fast
through mountain signs
[Music]
all i had to do was feel like the stars
[Music]
shine
[Music]
take this moment hold
all that you can sunset's golden
i fold up in your hands and feel this
close
time you stroll through the past
[Music]
when all i had to do was love
you stronger than the battle of the
[Music]
shadows of the night
farther than the water falling fast
through mountainsides
[Music]
wider
[Music]
on the wind
[Music]
stronger than the battle of your shadows
[Music]
all i had to do was love feel like the
[Music]
stars
[Music]
you